SPEAKER 1: Do you see
now how the first check
on the government is
that we must consent?
But the second check is that
we do not run the government.
In America, in the government
of the United States,
in the federal
government, what is
it that the people do
absolutely none of?
AUDIENCE: Make the laws.
AUDIENCE: Creating
the judiciary branch.
AUDIENCE: Enforcing the laws.
SPEAKER 1: They are not judges.
They are not legislators.
And they are not
executives over the law.
They are entirely excluded
from the operation
of the government.
Isn't that odd?
Right?
In England and Great
Britain, at the time
of the American Revolution,
who was the executive?
AUDIENCE: The king.
SPEAKER 1: And his
ministers, right?
And who was the sovereign?
AUDIENCE: The king.
SPEAKER 1: The king, right?
So the one possessing
legitimate title to rule
occupied the executive branch.
In Athens, who was
the legislature?
AUDIENCE: The people.
SPEAKER 1: The people.
And who was the sovereign?
AUDIENCE: The people.
SPEAKER 1: The people.
Athens, just the
people would meet,
and they were always
changing their mind.
And so in America,
it is different
because unlike Athens, unlike
England, all the sovereignty
is ours.
We may not be governed
except by our consent.
And if we don't give
it, no governing.
All government is
illegitimate except with that.
And of course, it
follows from that that
in the practical operation of
the government, since unanimity
is impossible, majority rule.
And of course, in a college--
in a proper college--
if you disagree,
somebody's wrong.
We're here to find out who's
wrong, and who's right.
Well, we always disagree.
How are we ever going
to figure it out, right?
But yeah, so there's
going to be voting,
and there's going
to be disagreement,
and we're not going
to reach unanimity.
Why is the majority
the right thing?
AUDIENCE: It seems
like it's more probable
that more people, since
it's not a mob at that time
because they're voting on
something in a republican
fashion, that they would have
considered it in a way that
would refine their opinions.
SPEAKER 1: Ooh,
that's really novel.
I don't think it's true.
All men are created equal.
You got 300 people.
160 want to do A,
and 140 want to do
not A. If you do
what the 140 says,
you've got yourself
an aristocracy, right?
In other words, the
majority of equal souls
has to stand in for
the unanimous consent.
And in anything not
fundamental or anything
that involves the ongoing
operation of the government,
that's what you need, see?
So the point is, you're going
to have majorities rule.
You're going to
have representation.
And that gives rise
to something new.
And Madison says that it's
never happened before.
It's unique.
The sovereign is the people
as expressed by what--
I'll introduce a new phrase
that Abraham Lincoln liked--
"The people, as they
express their wealth
through their
constitutional majority,
is the only true sovereign
of a free people."
And so that's where
sovereignty is.
That's where the right to say
the legitimate title to rule
is.
But those people, the
sovereign, are entirely
excluded from the operation
of the government.
Do you see now how the first
check on the government
is that we must consent?
But the second check
on the government
is that we who have
the power to consent
do not run the government.
And that second check
is a check on us.
The federalist answer is that
every human exercise of power
must be restrained by reason.
And there are
constitutional forms
that have to be implemented
that can help bring that out.
And if the first
constitutional form
is representation,
the method by which we
give our ongoing
consent, the second
is the separation between
sovereignty and power.
So you get consent.
And that gives rise
to representation.
to a separation
between the sovereign
and the government.
And Madison says this has
never been done before.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.